well for well more than a century people
in this country Americans have made the
case for socialism but that seed has
never really sprouted and taken root but
that's changing young Americans appear
to be every poll shows souring on our
economic system capitalism Ilan Omar and
Alexandria Kazuya Cortes set the agenda
of the modern Democratic Party and both
them call themselves socialists it's
affecting the presidential field you
could see it every day
here's one example on ABC recently
senator Bernie Sanders of Vermont
blasted his rival is with Warren with
the worst insults he could think of
she's a capitalist descent but there are
differences between Elizabeth and myself
Elizabeth I think as you know has said
that she is a capitalist to her bones
I'm not and the reason I am NOT is
because I will not tolerate for one
second the kind of greed and corruption
and income and wealth inequality and so
much suffering that is going on in this
country today which is unnecessary
another difference is he might be
actually even more self-important than
she is what you decide any case in 2019
that's a real attack on the left my
opponent is a capitalist whatever they
choose to call the Democratic base is
demanding socialist policies and
increasingly the candidates are happy to
oblige tell you what I believe in terms
of democratic socialism I agree with
what goes on in Canada and it's
Scandinavia guaranteeing health care to
all people as a human right I think
undocumented people need to have a means
by which they can be covered when
they're sick raise your hand if covered
if your government plan would provide
coverage for undocumented immigrants
[Applause]
socialism with open borders that's trend
Senator Rand Paul of Kentucky is
fighting it it's got a brand new book
out it's called the case against
socialism he joins us tonight thanks so
much for coming on thank you so congrats
on the book by the way and I bet I think
your book tour is probably a very
interesting window into where we are
right now my deeper question is why are
we there most of the economic indicators
seem positive why are people embracing
socials it was kind of an extraordinary
thing
remember when i was a kid we would say
well that liberal that liberal is
probably a socialist but they would
never admit to otally now you have
people actually running on the label of
being a democratic socialist I think
some of it is they've forgotten their
history so part of our book we talk
about the fact that Hitler was the
socialist the fact that Stalin was the
socialist the fact that mal was and then
about a hundred million people died in
the last century primarily from genocide
and famine and primarily from
collectivism and socialism but they seem
to have forgotten that but what they now
point to is they all say well we kind of
work for Castro but not so much any
we've kind of for Chavez in Medora but
not so much what we're really for is
Scandinavian socialism so we spend a lot
of the book describing the fact that
Scandinavia first is not socialist well
we also report that you know what
Bernie's actually too much of a
socialist
Tevan get elected at Denmark the prime
minister of Denmark said Bernie quit
calling a socialist were not socialist
were open for business and you're
ruining our business by telling the
world we're socialist and we're not well
the socialism of Norway is based on oil
deposits it's a petro socialist state
what's interesting though is that
conservative off conservative often say
socialism makes people poorer but the
people who run socialist systems always
want a very rich I've noticed we make
that point in the book that there's
always a top 1% in our country it's
largely based on merit in socialism it's
largely based on who you know whether
you're related to Maduro you know you
are wealthy and can have plenty to eat
so for example in Venezuela the average
person has lost twenty pounds over the
last year Maduro has gained about 50
pounds over the last couple years of the
door oh yeah he can't even wear clothes
I mean it's Oh Maduro is so fat his
generals are fat they're all well fed
but the average person is lost 20 pound
that is a statement of what the top 1%
is like in socialism so it doesn't cure
I mean because I think it is fair this
is a concern I have if inequality
becomes so profound it causes
instability in your society I think it's
part of the reason we're seeing now but
socialism is not the cure for that right
and actually we look at income
inequality also and find that the
studies by Thomas Piketty and others
really aren't true it actually turns out
that if you look at income and
quality and developed nations income
inequality is actually proportional to
economic growth it doesn't slow down
economic growth at all and really what
we should be concerned about you know
which society would you rather live in
where the average poor person makes
$30,000 a year and the average risk
person makes a hundred thousand or the
average poor person make sixty thousand
and the rich people make four million it
really shouldn't matter what a rich
person makes you really want the average
that the poor folks make to be
increasing and that's what's happening
in Calvinism envy is real so I have to
ask you about the Syrian question since
you're one of the very few elected
officials in Washington who appears to
be at least sympathetic to the
president's position that we ought to
pull troops out of northern Syria why is
the response been bipartisan and
outraged almost universally here
everyone hates this idea it's sort of
one of the strange compromises in
Washington they all seem to be in favor
of continued intervention everywhere
they never believe you can come home
when President Trump talked about coming
home from Afghanistan the immediate
response was it would be precipitous and
I'm like 19 years and it's precipitous
to come home so really it's really
appalling but there seems to be almost
nobody really looking at the situation
but will tell you one extraordinarily
thing for months I've been saying you
know what this best chance the Syrian
Kurds have is actually making an
alliance with Assad to protect them
against the Kurds that's already
happening as we speak they're beginning
to have an alliance their best chance of
having some kind of autonomous zone is
being part of Syria and reassuring
turkey that they're not going to be
making incursions into Turkey that's
what happened in Iraq there is a
semi-autonomous region for the Kurds but
they're within the government of Iraq
and they've gotten the assurity that
they're not going to invade into Turkey
interestingly there are 1800 Turkish
businesses in Kurdistan the Kurdish area
of Iraq now they actually are getting
along pretty well that could happen in
Syria too but we've prevented it because
we keep saying you can't talk to Assad
Assad must go but really you probably do
have to eventually talk to Assad to have
peace there of course it's not even
clear why we're saying that that's very
confusing senator thank you very much
great to see if I can get some grass on
the book thank you